[Music]
fashion is all about standing out while
following the latest trend this is why
we sometimes end up looking like someone
else when we wanted to be unique and
this time the outfit was so popular that
even objects decided to copy these
people make sure you watch this video
until the end to see the ultimate winner
of who wore it better if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you 15 who wore it better pics
that will make you laugh out loud a bus
passenger vs Eric Cartman most people
don't like to take the bus twice a day
to go to school or to work but someone
had a nice surprise this morning when
they saw a stranger sitting on the bus
he looked just like one of our favorite
cartoon characters could you guess who
it is
with that red sweatshirt his brown pants
and this blue and yellow beanie this man
looks just like the Eric Cartman from
South Park they're so similar that it
looks like this man intended to do this
all he needs is some yellow gloves and
the disruptive behavior to be a
real-life Cartman who won the who wore
it better contests we think that as the
bus passenger Zayn Malik versus ice
cream he was one of our favorite singers
when he was in one direction and what
really made him stand out from the group
was his hair he changed it a lot over
the years and it was always something
that made him different however we found
one thing that looked just like him so
Zayn is not the only one with this
hairstyle anymore just look at this
chocolate and vanilla ice cream even
though this street tastes really good
meeting the famous singer would be even
more amazing so we'll have to say that
he's the one who wore it better Kanye
West versus a pub he used to be known as
a recording artist but now he's even
more famous because he's married to Kim
Kardashian Kanye West is a fashion icon
and we can see him wearing a lot of
unique things like this outfit mostly
made of fur however he has some
competition because this cute pug
decided to wear a lot of fur too or
maybe the dog was just inspired by his
idol and can't wait for a Yee clothing
line for dog anyway we think that the
Pug wins the who wore it better this
time we're not able to resist these
puppy-dog eyes the nail-polish versus
the gum one of the newest trends on
social media is to make sure that your
nail polish matches everything and we're
not only talking about your outfit but
anything around you people are showing
off their manicure next to food like
meat orange juice
chicken strips Pepsi bottles and more
but there is one
girl who found out out of nowhere that
she was the victim of this trend - she
started today by painting her nails
white with some blue and green little
dot then by the afternoon she just
wanted a piece of chewing gum and
realized that it looked just like her
nails Nicki Minaj versus a cat the
singer became popular around 2010 with
her album pink Friday
this is how she became the first female
solo artist to have seven songs on the
Billboard Hot 100 at the same time
people immediately noticed her eccentric
style which made her stand out from all
the other rappers we think that we found
her biggest fan because there is someone
who looks just like her just look at
this funny cat with a green hat that
might be cheaper than the wig but we
have to give him two thumbs up for the
efforts and the unique idea the only
thing missing is a smile but we will let
this big kitty win the contest anyway
because he's making everyone smile even
more with this funny hat Nicki Minaj vs.
candy floss this singer didn't get to
the top by giving up after all it took
her years to finally stand out from the
other rappers when she started her
career and now she has to prove that she
is the most stylish woman out there with
her new pink wig we just have to look at
it for a second to know who she's gonna
be competing with candyfloss
it looks like this is what she's wearing
on her head and we just hope the sugar
won't melt this time we'll let the
singer say that she is the one who wore
it better not a lot of people can look
good with candy floss on their head
grandma versus the carpet we like it
when everything goes well together in
our home and when we visit Grandma we're
always amazed by how much time she
spends taking care of this beautiful
place for our visit check out this fun
lady who added one more thing to make it
the best place in the world
her dress matches the carpet it just
seems like she used the same fabric to
decorate her home and create an outfit
we'll have to give her bonus points for
lying on the floor just to take this
picture she was probably one of the
funniest grandmas in the world and just
for that we think that she's the one who
won the contest Justin Timberlake versus
noodles back in the 90s the singer was
part of the popular boy band NSYNC
Justin Timberlake is still really famous
nowadays and this is why we like to make
fun of him with this who wore it better
contest this time his hair is competing
with something hair should never look
like noodles and not even good noodles
the singer looks like he has cheap
noodles on his head
we can't believe that we had a crush on
that even though we'll never be able to
keep ourselves from falling in love with
the singer we have to admit that we love
noodles even more food will always be
there for us
in bieber versus grilled cheese and
here's another Justin for the younger
generation
the singer became one of the most
popular artists in the world when he was
only a cute teenager love him or hate
him you have all heard one of his songs
before and now he wants everyone to know
that he grew up by showing us that he
can be a bad boy Justin Bieber went from
the cute boy next door to a grilled
cheese if you don't believe us just look
at this picture of him next to this meal
the two look like they come from the
same store not everyone likes the singer
but everyone loves cheese so the food
will win a man versus shopping bag going
shopping is a great and terrible
experience at the same time we all know
what it's like to go to Target to buy
sunscreen and come back with a hundred
and fifty dollars worth of things we
didn't even know existed as you can see
these people are not an exception as
their car is now full of what they
bought during their 20-minute trip to
the store however it's not as bad as it
looks because there are actually only
two bags what is the third thing it's
just a man wearing a flannel shirt who
decided that he was going to participate
in who wore it better and we have to
admit that it took us a second before we
clearly understood what was right in
front of us
Donald Trump versus corn being the
President of the United States is the
best way to get attention
it doesn't matter on which planet you
lived in 2016 we have all heard and seen
the Donald Trump means but what inspired
people the most was actually his hair we
don't even understand what is this thing
on his head when we see it in the wind
but some Internet users found the answer
in a field he just hired corn as his
hairstylist but even though he likes
vegetables we cannot say that he looks
cool as a cucumber the corn wins this
time Donald Trump versus a caterpillar
the President of the United States likes
when people talk about him so that's
what we'll do but before he was the
leader of one of those powerful
countries in the world Donald Trump was
actually a businessman and a television
personality
it looks like Donald Trump is a little
caterpillar turned into a butterfly and
we think that we found a picture of the
president when he was a young boy just
look at the picture of this weird
caterpillar
it must be how Donald Trump's hair grows
the caterpillar is definitely the winner
of who wore it better a man versus road
cones
most people who know what it's like to
drive a car on the road know how there
is nothing more irritating than
construction and traffic this tourist
came to a big city and saw so many road
cones at
where that he thought it was the latest
trend this is why he decided to dress
just like one just look at him walking
down the street with his friends there
is no way we cannot notice him and we
think that this man should be the winner
of this contest at least he can get out
of our way if we need to go somewhere
Katy Perry Katy Perry always catches our
eye with her beautiful look and this is
how her songs get the attention they
deserve from I kissed a girl too swish
swish she is still more popular than
ever
once again Katy Perry stood out on the
orange carpet with her outfit inspired
by lime she was wearing a bright green
crop top skirt and dress and her hair
was colorful just like it always is we
think that this outfit inspired someone
because this beautiful puppy is wearing
the same color too this time it will be
really hard to decide who wore it better
we all love Katy Perry but at the same
time we can't say no to this puppy
sorry Katie but the ball of fluff is the
winner of the contest yellow sweatshirt
versus ice cream and last but not least
is a man who didn't even know that he
was participating in a contest he just
decided to wear a comfortable yellow
sweatshirt and brown pants before
falling asleep on a bench and he never
thought that this nap would turn him
into an internet sensation
that's because Internet users noticed
that he looked just like a delicious
lemon ice cream but there is one
question that will never be able to
answer what do we prefer sleeping or
eating we think that we'll have to make
them vote winners of the contest we need
those two wonderful things in our life
what is the funniest to work better on
our list don't be shy to tell us who it
is in the comment section down below we
love to hear from you and that's it for
15 who wore it better pics that will
make you laugh out loud for more stories
like this make sure you watch 10 people
who look like random thing thanks for
watching
[Music]